le drame se serait produit hier en toute
fin d'après midi mais ce n'est que ce
matin que les corps sans vie de deux
hommes d'une cinquantaine d'années ont
été retrouvés ici au domaine porcheron
de fontenay près chablis ces deux hommes
seraient deux frères qui appartenait au
domaine viticole et les évoluer dans une
cuve qui était actuellement en travaux
pour une mise aux normes alors seule
certitude qui nous a été communiquée ce
matin par la procureur de la république
d'auxerre c'est que la piste
accidentelle serait à privilégier une
disqueuse thermique a été saisie pour
l'instant le périmètre est bouclé ici
autour du domaine porcheron la section
scientifique de la gendarmerie et le
médecin légiste sont actuellement en
train de travailler pourrait tenter de
déterminer les causes de ces décès